just in tonight from the clark county
school district absentee among staff
members take a look at these numbers
this week the district reporting
1502 absences again for staff compared
to the return from that five-day pause
on friday january 21st the district saw
1571 absences but the highest number
coming in the friday before president's
day with the number of staff
missing work at 1
854. that number showing teacher
absences are actually growing
especially on mondays and fridays mary
jane bellies is sharing why some
teachers are not in the classroom
the clark county school district
collects teacher and student absence
numbers weekly but it doesn't explain
the reasons for those absences teachers
i spoke with say it's a combination of
sickness dealing with violent incidents
and simply being burnt out kristen nigro
is a teacher at steve shore elementary
school people are still testing positive
it might not be as much as what we have
seen in the past um but i also too
people are extremely nervous that even
if they get a slight tickle in their
throat or if they sneeze and cough
they're more you know apt to be at home
rather than come in and try to infect
everybody else vicki kreidel the
president of the national education
association of southern nevada says the
growing number of violent incidents at
schools have many teachers scared to
come to work if a teacher comes to me
and says i can't take it anymore i can
recommend you know care solas try to get
them some help sometimes they end up
going off on fmla because
it's too much to top it all off krydell
says teachers are simply burnt out most
of the people who are telling me they're
resigning are resigning to leave
education and that's what scares me
they're not leaving to go work at
another district because there isn't any
other districts here nigro anticipates
the teacher absence numbers will drop as
the weather gets warmer the weather
being nice and people coming back to
school we're you know really close to
spring break too
so we just gotta as educators power
through the rest of the school year and
put this one in the books this is
definitely one for the books the staff
absences have also caused another
problem a shortage in substitute
teachers a new regulation passed by the
department of education does permit over
500 emergency subs to teach in clark and
washoe county schools for the remainder
of this school year and next year if
nevada remains under a state of
emergency
we also reached out to the school
district ccsd saying it supports the
department of education's decision to
have emergency subs adding quote with
the nationwide teacher shortage school
districts across the state and country
must utilize every option to pair
teachers with students to raise academic
performance and satisfy the social
emotional well-being of our students